ليه فتره طايح في وسط مهبل
[موسيقى]
كلمه قلتها وانتهت
طال عمرك
[موسيقى]
رجل
يعني مرتاح ماديا كويسه
فهو كانت كل حياته مسخرها لهذه البنت وكان
بها توصل الى نقاط معينه في ذهنه وارسلها
الدراسه الخارج بس هنا تصير عادل المساله
في الفيلم لما بترجع
واحد هلالي والثاني الاتحاد
يا هلا يا هلا
ما تحبين راس ابوك اول شيء
في الرياض
شخصيتي فيه
سكرتير محمد العيسى في الشركه
اما بالنسبه للفيلم افتتاح الفيلم اليوم
انا اكون صادق معك انا
اول تجربه
اني اني اشتغل في فيلم فاااا اشوف تجمع
اعلامي
رهيب جدا واولهم انت واياه قناه العربيه
اليوم انت اول فيلم لك
شارك فيه
طول المسيره مسيره الفنيه كله مسلسلات
كلها
مسلسلات تلفزيونيه لكن
بعد ما
حكومتنا الله يطول في عمرها تحت السينما
اهو تحت السوق
[موسيقى]